I'm an entrepreneur I want to learn how
to have more confidence where am I going
right I want them to come to me am I
talking to my mom like where am I going
to go if I'm an entrepreneur and I know
that I have a self-confidence issue
where am I going to go to try to improve
that right they're going to YouTube when
they're searching through my confidence
and especially if you're talking to a
niche like you're targeting
entrepreneurs then it's a lot more
specific the coaching show is whatever
you want to sell show me the process of
you doing it so if you don't have an
email list yet you can even look at
who's following you on Instagram and
message people and say hey I'm going to
do a free coaching session for people
who wants 25 minutes of my time for free
to talk about coaching whatever issue
you have you're an entrepreneur whatever
confidence issue you're facing right now
I will quote you for free but it's going
to be online those are two different
shows though the biz Dev show is we're
trying to build a relationship with a
potential client and get them on the
show to tell their story but then inject
a little bit of what you do 25 of the
show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straight up coaching show where
they know they're coming on okay but
they may not be an ideal client for you
which is anybody who needs okay okay
because I need I want to see that you're
a good coach because you can talk and
you can give me your Frameworks XYZ and
you can you can have all of your
material but that makes you a good
speaker how do I know if you're a good
coach right like Ted Williams is a great
baseball player but he wasn't a great
coach so you could be a great speaker it
doesn't mean you're a good coach so how
do I know if you're a good coach I need
to see you coach
my challenges I have is not getting the
um videos made it's the description the
SEO the descriptions I am having the
devil of the time
all right good well let's dive in and do
this so let's start with this
I have a coaching program for small
business owners who are having the
challenges to make positive decisions
and I that's what I was going to
actually work with you with it's called
My XYZ formula I help X do y by z i help
small business owners make
profitable
easy profitable decisions through
positive questioning so I help them
through the questions I may not give
them all the answers but I probe them
with the questionings to help them come
up with a a better decision in the in
the end what's your YouTube channel bs4
entrepreneurs.com this
that is that is us is that you me and my
wife the first thing is we've got to
zoom in on that we're going to zoom in
on that picture because people are going
to see this small they're going to see
it like at this size okay so like that
could be anybody right so we got to zoom
in on your faces like big face here big
face here if you're both going to be on
it we've got to zoom in and then get
then get some decent lighting because
even even here the lighting is just like
her hair is kind of everywhere if we go
down you see this guy I mean he's got
glasses that's not great but let's see
if anybody else is doing a decent job in
here she's okay okay like I want to be
able to instantly see your face
right
like if you see her show up again the
glasses is not great but when I go and
see yours okay like that's way too far
out so zoom in on the face okay BS of
Entrepreneurship podcast let's go let's
go see what we've got in here all right
so we got some videos popping so first
video is
horses horses healers how Equine Therapy
is empowering you to overcome stress and
Trauma so tell me about the strategy
here with this video so we're doing
you're bringing guests
to talk about
um more African-Americans getting into
horse riding okay it has been a hundred
percent about the business owner
zero about my business or my wife's
business and it's been about
um getting more I guess getting more
views or trying to try attempting to get
more views rather than
um the business aspect or the business
side of it okay so you got there's two
different strategies here right if the
if the strategy is
I'm gonna bring on business owners who
are potential clients for you it's a
it's a business Dev show that's what we
talked about today in mover makers if we
look at the you know Equine Therapy
woman is she a potential clients uh the
direct answer is yes
okay great so the whole point of doing
the show is not to get views and
subscribers for the channel that's
that's a nice boost the point of the
show was to try to get clients we try to
do our best after the show is done to
optimize and rank Etc but we're trying
to build relationships with ideal
clients or referral Partners so if
you're trying to Target entrepreneurs
you bring a lawyer on because what's the
lawyer doing talking to entrepreneurs
all day long so yeah so the biz Dev show
it's just about building a relationship
we have to inject your confidence
questions in there so that they know
that you're a confidence coach and
hopefully by the end of it she's like
man I want to hire Frankie to help me
with this and there's follow-up
afterwards says say hey if you need help
with your confidence or whatever comes
up on the call you're the guy hi so
we're using it to try to align clients
right maybe she's ready now or maybe
she's ready in a month or two months or
whatever but that's the per the purpose
of the biz Dev show is to help you grow
your business and we're making videos
because that's how we get them on the
show
but it's not so much about we need this
Equine Therapy video to really pop off
hard because they're building a
relationship
so the different content strategy if you
want a Content strategy around coaching
that's what we're doing in the future
Movie Makers but then that's where you
bring on people to to coach so you you
bring on entrepreneurs and you coach
them through your process
so something's going to come in and say
hey Frankie I need help with blank so
do you have an email list should you
have people who you do not already in
your ecosystem but I don't I don't have
a I guess a basically a sales funnel to
have
um
customers coming to the funnel I do I do
not um I am totally weak
okay you don't need a giant funnel yet
but the coaching show is whatever you
want to sell show me the process of you
doing it so if you don't have an email
list yet you can even look at who's
following you on Instagram and message
people and say hey I'm going to do a
free coaching session for people who
wants 25 minutes of my time for free to
talk about coaching whatever issue you
have you're an entrepreneur whatever
conference issue you're facing right now
I will Coach you for free but it's going
to be online okay those are two
different shows though the biz Dev show
is we're trying to build a relationship
with a potential client and get them on
the show to tell their story but then
inject a little bit of what you do 25 of
the show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straight up coaching show where
they know they're coming on
but they may not be in they may not be
an ideal client for you this is anybody
who needs okay okay
because I need I want to see that you're
a good coach because you can talk and
you can give me your Frameworks XYZ and
you can you can have all of your
material you can but that makes a good
speaker
how do I know if you're a good coach
right like Ted Williams was a great
baseball player but he wasn't a great
coach so you could be a great speaker it
doesn't mean you're a good coach so how
do I know if you're a good coach I need
to see you coach
so you that's a that's a separate series
on the channel so now we're splitting it
up between the biz Dev show where we're
trying to get clients and a coaching
show where we're we don't care if
they're ideal clients are not coming on
We're just trying to show coaching and
help them of course and help them and
then if you have your website or you
build out your funnel that then becomes
content so when somebody lands on your
hey hire Frankie to be your coach I can
see examples of what you do and how you
coach people okay got it got it got it
is there a process to attempt to get
more engagement on a post so for those
two shows it's not so much about
engagement
they're they're we're accomplishing
different things so
the biz Dev show again it's not about
the audience it's about building a
relationship with the person because
they might be a client or they might
refer clients to us for the coaching
show it's really just to show that
you're a great coach and shift that
person when they're with you one-on-one
like because when you're coaching it's
not always the most engaging stuff like
I'm here coaching you I'm not okay
looking at the comments like we've got
the live audience right now people are
leaving comments and they're saying I
don't know what they're I'm not I'm
paying attention to you because I'm
coaching you the point of this is
hopefully that in you learning other
people watching will learn as well
but it's not
set up to be an engaging episodic that
okay if it was and I'd be I'd be
interrupting you every five seconds to
read every comment that comes in and
then we react to it but then that's a
different show right so if you're doing
that then you're you're not um
showcasing how much of a coach you are
because when you're coaching you got to
stay with the person not get distracted
by everything else but we don't have two
different two different channels or or
does does the coaching do I upload the
coaching content onto the podcast
Channel Once once I I can put on
something it could be the same channel
same channel because it's it's too much
work to maintain like it's hard enough
to do one channel
now if you're going to do multiple
channels that the work just multiplies
so at the beginning it's easier to do
okay one channel that's the easiest
place to start like that's how we start
to grow our coaching business there are
three shows that we talk about in
movement makers and we're going to go
through them so you're you're here like
right at the right time so the first
show was Biz Dev which we talked about
today the next one is coaching which
we're going to talk about coming up but
you can already go in and watch the
modules and learn all about it so you
also don't have to wait for us to get
there and movement makers
um and then the third show is thought
leadership and that's where you're
talking direct to camera
that's where we're really focused on
getting the views on the videos to
expose you as a thought leader you're
going to make a video of like the seven
ways entrepreneurs can improve their
confidence
that's what we're trying to make videos
that get something to get exposure those
videos be okay 10 minutes plus okay
people will watch if I'm an entrepreneur
I want to learn how to have more
confidence where am I going right I want
them to come to me
right am I talking to my mom like where
am I going to go if I'm an entrepreneur
and I know that I have a self-confidence
issue where am I going to go to try to
improve that right they're going to
YouTube when they're searching how do I
improve my confidence
and especially if you're talking to a
niche like you're targeting
entrepreneurs then it's a lot more
specific so if you're not your XYZ
framework is not just for anybody I'm
sure it can apply to everybody but
you're excited about trying to help
business owners apply the process yeah
so right and so so I can kind of go on
I can probably go on Google and and see
what the top searches are of how to
about I can just go into Google see what
the top searches are about confidence
and then kind of make videos around that
particular topic
yeah so what I would do is look at
so here I'll flip the camera and again
we go through this and movement makers
the training is there but just a high
level overview what would a video be
actually like what would you call it
what do you want to call a video we'll
just demo this live what do you what
would you call a video three tips for
better confidence
so right away
if you guys can see this I put in three
tips and see what's coming up now the
first suggestion is three tips to boost
your confidence
so you said three tips for better
confidence but the number one video
suggests is three tips to boost your
confidence
and you're my like that's the same thing
right is there a difference between
boost your confidence and better
confidence it's like it's the exact your
three tips are going to be exactly the
same thing but you see what people are
actually searching for so you should
call your video boost your confidence
okay right that's how we start to get
more attention for that's what people
are searching for but we can we'll go a
little deeper so that's one way to do it
you'd like three tips and some of these
are not you know going to be relevant
like I don't know what a lot of these
things are but confidence is right there
number one so three tips we'll still go
with yours for uh better
confidence
Okay so these are all the videos that
are showing up for three tips for better
confidence right now we're trying to the
way to win was with YouTube is often you
want to rank after other people's videos
so
I have a plugin called vid IQ that if
you want to write that down it's just
vid IQ and there's a free version of it
and the reason why I use it is for every
video that shows up it shows me how many
subscribers that channel has
and so what we're looking for is a video
that has more views than subscribers
so the number one video says three tips
to boost your confidence so we could do
that it's got nine million views it's
still pretty good but the channel has 18
million subscribers
so we're trying to do is is find videos
this has one million views 10 million
subscribers let's see what else we got
here 600 000 views 900 now we're getting
now we're getting closer views and
subscribers so this this could be a fun
video to make of how to build your
confidence and know your worth hashtag
girl talk so maybe the girl talk is not
going to be
for you but take that out right take out
the girl talk and make a video how to
build your confidence and know your
worth you can make this video right how
to build confidence and know your worth
but you may not never think to make that
video called that
so this is where the research helps is
that you can then make this video title
and just take out the girl talk
let's keep going okay look at this this
is great this guy has 24 subscribers and
he got 8 000 views on his video
three tips to boost your confidence
Ted Ed
now that's maybe some Ted Ed talk we're
gonna We're not gonna do Ted Ed but we
want to try to rank after this video so
the goal is when somebody's watching
this video they watch yours next
that's our goal that's how we win and so
I don't know how many subscribers how
many subscribers you have you have like
40 subscribers on the channel
um great they got 8 000 views on this
video like that's a really that's
probably their best video on their
channel so we want to make a video
called three tips to boost your
confidence
and again we started with three tips for
better confidence but we're not gonna go
with this title we're gonna go with
three tips to boost your confidence
and this is what we're looking for right
like this number one video had nine
million views but it's from a really big
channel 18 million subscribers
this one has no subscribers and you got
8 000 views so that's what we're looking
for small channels where the videos did
really well because that gives you a
shot to win too so you should make a
video called three tips to boost your
confidence and then whatever comes to
mind right and then you just keep going
down with all these videos that you
would probably call it
um you look at this one they have a
hundred and so Tam Cower has 199 000
subscribers and she's got 778
000 views on this video in two months
mm-hmm
it's a good number right so her video
Title Here is how to build real
confidence self-worth tips magnetic
confidence beat insecurities and glow up
right you could do that maybe maybe not
the glow up part I don't know unless
you're gonna glow up but like take this
title and make your version right
because she got
700 000 views in two months and you know
I don't know who she is but I think you
probably know a lot about confidence
that she may not know
right so this is how we start to do
research on videos because you would
never like magnetic confidence may never
be a word that you would use but you
could right unless you have aversion to
the word for some reason right or like
beat insecurities you may not naturally
think of making a video on that but
that's what people are looking for so
the goal is to rank people watch Tam's
Video and then boom there's Frankie
right afterwards
and so you can keep going through this
process and keep looking for videos that
I've done well that have more more views
than subscribers you know
powerful psychological trick to make
anyone addicted to you I don't know if
like that falls into your wheelhouse or
that's too far you know off
but again you want to make you want to
make videos that are authentic to what
you can actually talk about if that
doesn't work cool skip next right how to
look confident when you feel out of
place did you do that
yeah 10 million views 6 million
subscribers so this is a great video for
them and you don't need to watch this
video or know what he did I know this
channel is Charlie you don't care what
Charlie said you have your own
methodology your own framework your own
beliefs and systems that you know works
all we're trying to do is draft off of
videos that are already doing well
and come up with titles because that's
kind of how you start it's like how do I
come up with uh the descriptions don't
matter it's the title that matters the
most so how do I come up with titles
that are going to make people want to
click and it's easier when they're
already coming from popular videos so
you need you should make a video that
says how to look confident when you feel
like I can use that same title exact
same title yeah that's fine as as long
as it's authentic right again like one
was right blow up and one was uh I
forget what else was in there so like
you take that out but otherwise okay
yeah you've got you can take the same
title so those are the three main shows
that then you can work towards you've
got your you've got your Biz Dev show
and the point of Biz Dev show is to
bring ideal clients on if you don't
think they're an ideal client or they
could refer ideal clients to you then
they're not on the show I get the life
open on this morning was to
like uh pick entrepreneurs she was
entrepreneurs to come on to
entrepreneurial ship show and in our
mind uh well in my mind entrepreneurs
would probably watch it because I'm
talking to an entrepreneur entrepreneur
so yeah I I'm I really my mind has
really shifted yeah but they're coming
on and just listening to somebody else's
story
that doesn't why would I then hire you I
don't know you're just Larry King asking
questions you're a great question asker
right okay well I'm not hiring you for
that
so unless your goal is to be an emcee or
to host shows or something else then
then that's a different model right but
it's like I'm a coach and I want to sell
more coaching Services then that that's
a better model so you're bringing people
if they don't if they're either not an
ideal client meaning they have a
business and they can afford your
services like it was a brand new startup
and they're dead broke
it's an ideal client because they can't
afford you
so ideal clients or referral Partners
lawyers accountants those kinds of
people who deal with entrepreneurs all
day long like if you have the right
lawyer on and they love you they could
be referring everything so now to you I
I went through one of the um one of the
the chapters in the course about how to
make the the fastest way to make money I
believe it was the faster way to make
money and and we talked about
um reaching out to people who may be
able to pay us two thousand dollars per
month
would that be the two thousand dollars
per month just from from the coaching
program correct so I I would be
getting a business to pay me two
thousand dollars a month to coach them
and obviously to to show them that
that's two thousand dollars worth of uh
business too over two thousand dollars
is that that's how that would yeah so
you you need to think what what do I
offer for two thousand dollars a month
and that's a good starting point right
you get five clients and
um now you got a six figure business
so how do we get five clients at two
thousand dollars a month what do you
offer for two thousand dollar a month am
I on a call with you once a week am I in
a call every two weeks like what does it
look like what kind of value you're
bringing me I'm a business owner I want
to grow what are you gonna give me every
every what every week every two weeks
every month that makes it worth two
thousand dollars and then what size
business would be able to afford two
thousand dollars a month if somebody's
just getting started and they can't pay
their rent they're not paying you two
thousand they do they need you yes a
hundred percent
and that's that's like that's step five
you know like you want to change the
world with confidence right you know you
don't just want to coach five people and
then you're done you've got a message
it's gonna change the world but to make
that happen we need to get you paid
so that you can hire your team to help
you build and grow because if it's you
doing everything or the two of you doing
everything it's it's limited by what you
can do so it's how do we make money
inside of our mission to then be looking
for a team to really then blow up the
mission and and the fastest way usually
is coaching if you'd like to coach and
if you're a good coach and so if you're
a good coach you've got all the
ingredients to make it happen but it's
the selection of the people so who are
the entrepreneurs who can afford two
thousand dollars a month for coaching
with you
and that's where if you're talking to
people like lawyers and accountants and
bookkeepers
their clients
are are already hiring professionals
so they have budget to hire a lawyer and
hire a bookkeeper and not do it all
themselves so it's a higher level of
climb of sophistication and finances and
so those people could become potential
clients for you
like that one relationship with the
right lawyer might give you the final
clients and you're done
but you have to be talking to the right
people like confidence coaching can help
everybody but it doesn't mean everybody
can afford you yeah
and at the beginning that's where a lot
of people get stuck of like charging
fifty dollars a session or seventy
dollars a session or twenty five dollars
a session or something because that's
all that the client can afford it
doesn't mean that you are not bringing
value it's just they can't use that
value to the full extent yet
and so it's about getting and talking to
the right people and the biz def show is
is the easiest way to be able to do that
because they don't want to come and hear
you pitch them on confidence coaching
but they'll come on your show to talk to
you about their business and you're
building a relationship then they know
you like you trust you and then
inside the show
um maybe I think I said maybe said that
this morning from from where they should
do the business show and inside the show
showcase my talents of what I do for my
business inside that inside the show
yeah and it's so easy with you like for
some it's a little challenging but for
you it's every entrepreneur comes up on
your show you
transition from being Larry King
question asker to now I'm an expert and
you just tell them I'm so I'm a
confidence coach for entrepreneurs and I
help entrepreneurs unlock the next level
of their business by being more bold
having more courage and being more
confident
and that's what I do every day where do
you see confidence holding
you back in your business or what are
some of the biggest confidence
challenges you're seeing in your
business what does the next level look
like that you don't know how to get to
right whatever it is I'm just pulling at
things
like 10 different ways and and phrase it
10 different ways
whatever feels this is a hard question
like whatever feels right for you that's
authentic to kind of the business you're
trying to build and what you generally
help people with and then they're going
to share they're going to share and then
you talk quickly about that but you
don't turn the whole thing into a
coaching session you just talk quickly
about it there and then you can say and
I've got a few more ideas for you but
I'll tell you I'll tell you after the
show okay tell me about the horses again
and tell me about so you go back to this
yeah one show but I thought I was taking
too much I felt internally that I was
trying to focus too much on myself and I
I did that in one in one of the shows 25
is you okay
75 is the guest
so we're talking about the guess their
story why they're here yada yada yada
like questions that you genuinely care
about like hopefully you actually like
this person you're curious about them
right then in the middle you're gonna
bring up confidence
and what they think about it how it
applies to their business right now
you're going to talk quickly about it
maybe it's the XYZ framework maybe
something else that comes up to mind and
you can see like I've got more ideas for
you but we'll talk afterwards now we're
planting a seed that we're going to talk
afterwards
right so now when you send them an email
afterwards you already talked about
talking about it afterwards right
and then you go back to them
you don't want to end on them feeling a
lack of uh like them working out an
issue you know because it wasn't
designed to be a coaching show so then
we end going back to them about what's
next but they're excited by their big
product whatever and we're we're getting
information that we can use on our
follow-up email as well with them
afterwards so 25 you in the middle but
it's all about them at the beginning and
the end
so you need to talk but yeah if you're
taking up half the show talking about
confidence that's too much
for this show for the biz Dev show right
and then when the show is done you
message them hey Susan thanks for coming
out it was amazing
I love that you shared blank and I had a
I have got three ideas that I think are
gonna blow you away how about we hop on
a zoom next week and I'll I'll walk you
through it or tomorrow or whatever right
and and we'll walk through and get on a
call like don't try to do it over email
because you're magic okay come out in a
zoo
um now I can't I can tell you that
um going through the course I I did uh
end up purchasing build to serve because
you I think you you
um
uh mentioned
um a form I think you kept saying on
page 11. I haven't even I haven't even
seen the form I've just been so enamored
one of the first stages that uh here's
some type of framework what was the
framework that you were that you were
mentioning in in the in the in the bill
to serve there's a bunch of Frameworks
in there
um there's a thought leadership
framework that's to help you make your
long form videos like the third show is
thought leadership the direct the camera
the uh what we just looked up how to
look confident when you feel out of
place
we'll give your framework for how to do
it
so for a video like that the biggest
problem is people start videos in a
really poor way so the problem isn't
your description the problem is your
title right we're calling it uh tips for
better confidence instead of right so
better titles better thumbnails for sure
and in the opening minute has to hook
people and that too so from coming up
with a bold statement where I
um I previously would say hey hi hello
guys this is and you said nobody cares
about that yeah if you start a video hey
guys welcome back it's me Frankie your
confidence coach like welcome back I've
never been here before
who are you okay I don't care right but
here's the thing like people love
YouTube is great for long form content
people will watch an hour if it's good
but they have a short attention span in
the first minute because I'm trying to
decide uh do I give this guy I've never
seen them before do I give this guy my
attention or do I give it to somebody
else so that's why you got to bring him
in but if you keep him for a minute
they'll watch the whole thing so if you
think think about let's take that title
how to look confident when you feel out
of place
what's a powerful opinion what do you
believe about that that other people
don't believe how to feel confident when
you feel better rolling your shoulders
back will give you more power Standing
Tall makes you more powerful than 85 or
95 of the room
okay okay so don't give me a solution
yet lean in on the uh on the opinion
like what do you believe about looking
confident that other people don't
believe we're going to get to the advice
of what I need to do to fix it
but what do you believe about looking
confident that most people don't believe
um licking confidence gives you the
eyeballs you want
that's just I just that's just popped on
top of the back of my head because
looking confident can it be easy
is looking confident a skill that takes
eight years to figure out eight years
looking looking comp okay uh looking
confidence can happen in less than a
minute you can look confident in another
statement and that could be a bold
statement well that's a bold statement I
think if you said that to most people to
be like what are you talking about
Frankie that's not no most people you
think most people believe that they can
look confident in under a minute
I believe it
perfect
well that's what we're looking for like
what do you believe that other people
don't believe not the not the how-to so
you're going to teach me something I'm
going to roll my shoulders I'm going to
stand up straight I'm gonna whatever
you're gonna those are the tactics but
we don't lead with the tactics okay you
got to leave with the opinion
you can look confident in under one
minute
right so powerful opinions then it's
contact sentence which tell me a little
bit more about the thing you just told
me so like you can look confident under
a minute if that's my opening sentence
the second sentence just adds a little
more context to it so
you know the next time you're feeling
low in doubt going for a big interview
or sale and you feel like it's not going
to happen you can fix that in a snap
okay
and go get that sale right so like we're
we're just expanding on the first point
but we're not we're diving deeper into
the problem and not talking about the
solution yet because when you just leave
with Solutions people don't listen
so you gotta lead with the problem that
they're facing and your opinion about it
and then uh um the third sentence is
raise the stakes where you make this
bigger you're challenging the
perspective where you're saying uh
sentence like this would be something
like um and if you don't learn how to
quickly shift your confidence this will
hold you back from every negotiation for
the rest of your life so give them uh
something that they may lose bigger
you're making it bigger like I'm coming
in for one thing
and you're saying because confidence
connects to everything correct
like you believe that yes perfect no I
mean I don't want to give you something
like that you go home and be like I
don't I don't believe that
perfect
so they're coming in trying to solve one
little problem and you're helping them
realize no no that little problem is not
little like if we don't fix it it's a
huge life for the rest of your life Wow
so now like oh my gosh what is he
telling me now I really want to watch
his video
so so powerful opinion context sentence
race mistakes
um and it's inbuilt to serve and it's in
the movie maker training as well I'm
kind of going through it quickly just
for this but then you tell a story
so the story is your story uh a client's
story you've changed the name change the
gender change whatever so you're not
saying names but a story in the news you
know whether you used to lack confidence
or whether you had a client who you've
helped in and you're switching some of
the details or there's something about
in the news cycle whether it's you know
whoever is front page of the of the news
right now confidence good or bad and
you're going to tell the story around
that because the story is what connects
to people
so by going through that process
powerful opinion context senses race of
stake story
and you like Frameworks this is a good
framework to follow uh it connects you
to the person and they know that you
understand them right what's the quote
just like show people how much you care
they won't listen to what you know until
they know how much you care or something
like that you have to show them that
that you care because you're coming in
you look confident you're going to come
on camera you're going to be confident
and the immediate reaction is going to
be yeah but that guy was just born
confident I'm not like okay I came he
doesn't understand me so then the advice
doesn't matter because if I don't think
you understand me you could tell me
anything I'm not listening right as
coaches have we told people what to do
and then they don't do it
yeah because they feel you don't
actually understand they're like oh
that's easy for Frankie to say but look
at him he's so confident he doesn't
understand me but no no I do I've been
there I know until I went through that
so that connects us tell a story that'll
connect us and and connects to the to
the theme so the video is called how to
look confident when you feel out of
place you tell me a story when you felt
out of place you know at some point in
your life you failed out of place
and if you were to go back and tell
Frankie who was filling out a place
there you'd have some good advice for
him so
when I see you now like Frankie never
feels out of place like Frankie put his
hand up but movement makers is sharing
his stories here doing this what do you
mean he's out of place but that's why
you tell that story because now I want
you went on some kind of
transformational Journey to get to who
you are now I want to go on that same
Journey but when I see the end product I
don't think there's a journey there
right
so I need to know that there was a
journey I need to know that you are like
me like when I tell people that I'm shy
and introverted they don't believe me
that's right so I have to share for the
stories you connected me too
um I I literally
could probably connect it with you over
covet you're watching your videos over
covet and I because when you said hey
I'm a shy I'm an introvert literally
that is me that is me even though I I
internally overcome it because I know if
I don't overcome it what will happen so
that's what and because I'm I'm tall it
seems that uh IT projects out but I am a
shy introvert person and when you said
that
it was a done deal
but see something so it worked right and
and that's not like a sales pitch that's
what I actually had so same thing for
you like you have these stories you've
been through stuff but people don't know
that and they assume you're just you're
just Frankie naturally confident but you
had issues and so like tell me some of
those stories that that like me being
child introverted brought you into my
community you telling your stories would
bring people into yours
so the the three sentence at the top
powerful opinion contact centers raise
the stakes story that framework gets
people connected to you
now they understand that you know who
they are okay now okay oh they're ready
to listen and now we get to the advice
so so how do we do that how do we
actually what does it again feel
confident when you're out of place okay
step number one is I want you to roll
your shoulders back and stand up
straight
and then whatever two and three is too
right like you have the Frameworks and
the methodologies but if you lead with
that people tune out and don't listen if
you lead with the other staff now like
you've got them like this is the guy
who's gonna teach me and they'll follow
along for the advice
foreign
it's just a tweak like it's not you can
do all of that stuff it's not you have
the opinions you have the coaching you
have the knowledge you have the
information it's just making it we're
packaged into better so that people can
connect to it and connect to you so it
leads to better results
um if you suck as a coach that's harder
man okay
that's harder but
but if you're if you're a good coach
then which is just packaging around it
so that it can we can get you out to the
world
um so yeah so it's the three shows which
have three different purposes they can
all live on the same channel it's fine
but we'll just make sure we keep that
intent with each show so show number one
which is the most important show to
bring in immediate revenue is the biz
Dev show like if you only have to pick
one show it's the biz Dev show like I
need to make money next month I need
clients coming in it's the biz Dev show
and we're bringing on ideal clients or
referral Partners like lawyers Etc we're
telling their Story 25 is you jumping in
and then we create a relationship
show number two is the coaching show let
me see what you do and it's designed to
be a coaching show they're coming on
knowing they're going to be coached by
Frankie and you're going to give them
advice and then show number three is the
thought leadership show where you're
taking topics like how to look confident
when you feel out of place
and following that framework of powerful
opinions
okay yep you direct the camera yeah and
if it's if it's overwhelming and it's a
lot cool like step by step it's fine you
don't have to launch all three shows at
the same time start with the biz Dev
show get some clients
make more money use it to hire a team
use that time then to then work on the
second show and then work on the third
show right it's just giving you a
blueprint for where to go how fast you
want to attack each one is completely up
to you but typically
uh the problem a lot of people face at
the beginning of a journey is they only
do thought leadership shows or go all in
on I'll try to do all three and then
they can't commit enough time to each
one and then they end up quitting
because they're not making enough money
you're gonna make way more money from
coaching than you will from advertising
Revenue at the beginning of your journey
as you keep going the goal is whatever
you want speaking gigs courses books
tours Across America whatever I'm sure
you've got I'm sure you've got big ideas
for where you want to take the brain but
all of that requires an audience and
requires a team and requires finances to
make it all happen
how do you do that the biz Dev show get
clients start to scale question thing I
told him earlier I'm going to hire you
getting ready to open
the bridge you can come in and you can
speak to the agents here including
myself so I could be your guinea pig he
can use me and practice on me
um and of course I get it for free but
so listen you have you have two shows
Frankie like one you do the biz Dev show
by yourself or you bring on
entrepreneurs and you do 25 you 75 them
and that's you you and them and that's
the show and then the second show is the
coaching show which you could have your
wife on with you or somebody on your
team like the coaching show it could be
it's a free thing that you could do for
them but it's going to be a video so you
can coach her but then any new hire that
she brings on
could also go to YouTube for training
but it becomes a video around confidence
and so that's an easy way to get new
people coming in for you to coach and it
also helps your wife's business and
train up her staff
I've done my part
so I mean there's a lot and there's a
lot more in the course and we'll go
through all that and movement makers too
but I think that's your easiest next
best step figure out who's going to be
on the biz Dev show go make a list of
the entrepreneurs who could afford you
figure out what a two thousand dollar
plus a month coaching package looks like
for people and then also make a list of
Ideal referral partners
accountants lawyers Etc and then the
coaching show you start with your wife
and then whoever on her team that she
wants to bring in for you to coach as
well and so we have those two shows and
and that's the that's the start to see
me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there how do I get people to the live
you book people like we just did here
you talk to my assistant or my assistant
talk to your assistant or whatever and
here we are right like it was two
o'clock Eastern on Wednesday afternoon